[Music]
on today's news we're talking about one
of steve's favorite guys really hot hot
guy can we guess
how hot super hot
the rock who's the guy that steve thinks
is hot favorite guy the guy that made
ethereum
italic
it is italian no i was kidding you
talking about uh meth tom brady no oh no
no no i had to think about that first
thing but no uh um it's zilinski oh he's
very hot he's very hot yeah well that's
what i love about twitter and all this
stuff like all the chicks out there
going like dolinsky it's not hard
anybody else want to [ __ ] zalinski it's
like you guys
i'm glad i'm not the only one that
thinks that's weird it's so weird i'm
not the only one
i feel like any man in a powerful
position though just gets certain women
wet
do you think putin's getting people wet
right now oh yeah clinton did and so did
kennedy for sure yeah okay because even
um this defector this girl she defected
from north korea she was saying like
there was a time when she had the super
hots for
kim jong-un because he's hot because
that was the epitome of man you know oh
that makes sense so you look at a chubby
dude that looks like the pillsbury doll
boy and she's like super wet for them
and they're just training you to sit say
that's hot yeah well if the cover of
men's health every time is kim jong-un
you're like okay it's really it's peak
performance yeah you may not you might
not like it but this is what peak
performance looks like well they can't
because anybody else gets [ __ ] shot
and thrown into the uh yeah it's true
it's just like wow would you rather this
pudgy guy or this guy with a bullet in
his head
or that's malnourished washboard abs
gets you shot
how dare you be hot get fatter
so ukraine arrests a hit squad of 25 men
who are sent to kill presidency gangster
where they find them
the
let's see let's see a team of 25
assassins led by russia's secret service
we're arrested by ukrainian police on
the border triangle between ukraine
slovakia and hungary they've been
[ __ ] up a lot huh do you think
putin's pissed about this he's like hell
yeah you guys doing while he's eating
this pizza
25
25. not only did he lose dominoes he's
also [ __ ] can't even get the ukraine
he's getting a lot of crank calls too
[ __ ] tons of crap i got six meat lovers
but the thing is uh so this ukrainian
news agency were already told by kiev
counter intelligence sources that the
men were on their way to kiev
accompanied by a russian secret service
agent so that means that the group had
orders to kill zelinski and infiltrate
and sabotage other elements of the
ukrainian government not exactly moving
in the smallest group there i know
but obviously the attempt was already
tiff uh tipped off uh with the russian
secret service itself which doomed the
team from the start because somebody in
inside the russian secret service was a
tattletale tipped them off yeah
someone's a rat pretty bad
why why were they motivated to do that
well putin was distracted because he
thought he had a virus on his computer
and he was calling um the hotline that
came up because anonymous [ __ ] [ __ ]
him up he was like yeah he was like okay
so i have a virus i guess you guys got
to walk me through what i do
and then putin had to go to best buy buy
gift cards
what are you talking
about story you're talking about like
what putin's dealing with right now so
that's how they distracted him and he
had to pay a bunch of people in bitcoin
or something like a bitcoin machine yeah
gift card bitcoin yeah it was it was
nice it was a big story she's going down
st petersburg like [ __ ] did his
little car like
he is in his little car and his little
car [ __ ] they're busting his balls
with this [ __ ] he just he just clicked
the wrong thing trying to find the
download button yeah he's just trying to
update to windows 11 and then you know
he's [ __ ] now
and java
that's been now like discontinuing it
was out of date
just wanted to play [ __ ] flash games
in this video it won't work yeah you use
the flash player file
this ruined my [ __ ] russian vacation
plans too were you planning on rushing
that
so i um i was gonna do this trip with
hannah that's what he could think of
right now
it's uh train's getting carpenter
training ride from portugal all the way
to vietnam
not one train but it's a multiple of
seven days a [ __ ] trip yeah but you
could do this all in two weeks
isn't that [ __ ] nuts that's a lot
yeah but you'll be asleep like sleeping
in whatever in the train but the cool
thing is so it uh you could stop
wherever obviously and you have the
freedom to stay however how how many
other days you want but it goes from
europe all the way through russia down
china and then it ends in vietnam but
then world war iii is going on right now
so [ __ ] man ruin my [ __ ] travel plans
damn
you sound exactly like white chicks on
the [ __ ] on twitter that was the goal
but what about my european vacation my
kitchen mixer hasn't arrived yet
where's my kitchenaid kitchen mixer dab
you do that really well thank you i
think he is white
he doesn't use it he just needs the girl
accent i will [ __ ] cancel i bet you
will i bet you will don't you do it
careful there easy
i'll stick white twitter on youtube
right oh what are you gonna do [ __ ]
pinterest
they'll bite you with their gums i mean
there's no teeth
twitter.gov
is there an asian twitter
yeah yeah
what's that tweet
it's called wechat
it's called twitter twitter
but it's t-h-u-y
twitter
has been seen as the face of the
resistance to ukraine appearing on
camera and in public throughout the last
month to condemn the russian invasion
however this has seen him as a key
target for russian invaders with more
than a dozen
assassination attempts directed towards
the ukrainian president since the
invasion began
ukrainian ministry of defense reported
that zielinski had previously been
targeted by members of paramilitary
organization wagner group
who the kremlin has long denied any
direct you know them yeah they're like
they're kind of like the russian black
water so like a pmc group uh am i
supposed to say wagner i don't know
i mean it's like they're russian right
now wagner is kind of like german right
does black water still like operate no
they change their name change their name
yeah so they rebranded
blackwater still exists but blackwater
is like a like an accessories company
now but the actual like contracting
group is not the same name anymore they
rebranded something else but there are
other there are other scarier
like private military contractors that
exist they're just not they just don't
have their name cool thing like you know
like docile things like triple canopy
you know like freedom incorporation you
know what's funny triple canopy
beauty business
that's uh that's actually the parent
company to some of these contracting
companies that's a parent company holy
[ __ ] yeah so there's like a lot of those
five dollar cops by ralph's and [ __ ]
yeah
for the security test it's okay but it
does throw you off yeah that can't be a
parent company or something yeah it that
seems like the [ __ ] stepchild company
redheaded stuff i would love that if
like the most unassuming companies were
actually private military groups like
what like adriana's insurance
the whole time
call jacob
call jacob was an assassin yeah you mean
if i dial 888 888
like papa john's winchell's my god larry
h parker
no he's clearly running a ring out there
like he's he's doing something [ __ ]
the real life better call it's got to be
something else like pampers crazy
peppers gerber
baby food
damn
that's like um when i found out little
caesars is actually a food distribution
company
and then they're just piggybacking the
business off of their network which is
why their pizzas are so cheap yeah
that's all they could they're just
supplying all the other pizza places a
lot of uh yeah distribution for food and
stuff so i'm like smart yeah right so
there's probably businesses out there
that's like the whole mcdonald's being a
real estate company oh man i used to
think that little caesars had had it on
easy mode but then they had the batman
pizza with the calzone and i'm like this
is not easy to do
it was hard and it's actually hard you
looked at that and you're just like damn
some next little [ __ ] i'm like this is
first of all i was like i was like okay
wow cause i was you know i was on white
people twitter and i was like oh wow
this is the evolution of pizza shoreline
this is the future
wait what is the what is the batman
calzone is it shaped like that machine
yeah it's like the pizza that they like
folded some of the edges
is it the bat like the bat logo joe yeah
we're gonna show you it you tell me how
it works all right you tell me how the
[ __ ] you make that
you're telling me this engineering
marvel if i gave you two hours you
couldn't make that that's what i don't
understand about it i can make that i
can make that it's a pizza what the that
a knife right here knife right here
knife right here full what are you
talking about
that is this one's cutting snowflakes
over here in third grade all right in a
perfect circle it's like a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you oh yeah that looks like
a biblically accurate angel yeah you're
saying that it was just a circle that
they cut up yeah saying no way
you need to get an expert out next ask
the expert a little teaser franchisor
that looks like one of those band-aids
that you get when you have a really
small cut it looks like that looks like
one of the hundreds of things that are
getting sent to the kremlin to putin
is like
are you [ __ ] me again with this did
you see how anonymous made that attack
and they're going into their tv stations
and [ __ ] up with the footage like
they're they're streaming [ __ ] of the
war
because apparently a lot of russians
don't know that they're in ukraine yeah
a lot a lot of the soldiers don't know
that they're in ukraine to fight a war
they just give them wrong compasses no
they know that they were training
they told him like with the initial
invasion they captured some soldiers
that surrendered because they were like
bro what the [ __ ] this is a war like
they were like i thought we were
training doing a training exercise and
they're like we don't want to kill you
guys you got me wargames the game's over
what do we eat
wild
anyway were we talking about batman
pizza [ __ ] can't possibly be a supply
chain if all those pizzas can get to
russia
the supply chain doesn't exist it's a
supply train from portugal to vietnam
oh
how they're getting pizza oh my own
how are they getting pizza if uh
dominoes pulled out of the game domino's
is not the sole supplier
anyone who's still here for this video
we love you
dude what if they replace putin's jacket
so putin puts on his normal jacket and
then he goes to reach for his pen and he
pulls out his pocket
mozzarella where the [ __ ] is my pen do
you think he's gonna keep pulling
scarves out and a big [ __ ] rope top
scarf
you know i'm telling you they're
pranking putin good right now he's
distracted as hell this is when you
gotta strike do you think this is how
the psyops work is magic tricks yeah
this is what they're doing i'm telling
you so much [ __ ] about magic and now
you're like we should use this as a war
tactic we have spies inside of the
russian government people know this
they're [ __ ] with putin big time
right now we don't even know about it
you sound like alex jones this is the
information that i'm hearing that's all
i'm saying
we have people inside the kremlin they
got to his right now they got to his car
putting water in his water bottle to
make him gay
turn into the freaking putin gay that's
pretty good alex jones that's a good
joke i miss alex jones
i love the idea of fighting a war
criminal with just like store-bought
magic tricks
whoopee cushions and [ __ ] you never
expect everyone laughs at it they're
like classic you got to distract them
right yeah
people who laugh at him get murdered i
know
hey but he's distracted you know
i'm just saying it looked exactly like
his coat and that's what got him
the pizza coat
you